we don't want a new Rolex we just don't
want to sell someone's house
he's one of the vilified a landlord
forced to put rents up but Sean says
there's no choice due to mortgage rate
Rises and tax changes making it
impossible to offset costs can you
imagine a business any business
where you can't offset your costs
how is that possible it's now possible
this is very important for people to
realize it's now possible to make a loss
as a landlord and still pay tax
it's bonkers
we are not taxed on our profits we're
taxed on our turnover where is the spare
money I really don't know where people
are going to live there's there's a
there's going to be a housing crisis
it's it's in the post a massive crisis
it's catastrophic and that's because an
increasing number of landlords are
leaving the market figures given
exclusively to Sky News show a rise of
nearly 13 selling up in just four months
since July in October three quarters of
landlords who left letting agents did so
to sell their property
that's despite a housing market dip with
property prices falling
I feel hopeless
I'm trying my best
but I don't think
I have any chance or if I don't win the
water
tenants like Joanna are still stuck
renting partly due to Rising rents on 45
000 a year and yet saving for her own
home has never been so Out Of Reach I
feel very very sad I'm getting emotional
because I feel like I'm on a hamster
wheel
I'm running I'm trying my best I'm
getting extra hours second job and I'm
still struggling
I think it's Mission Impossible
so why should we care what happens to
landlords well we're now over reliant on
the private rented sector more people
are competing for the same space those
who want to buy a house but like Joanna
can't afford the deposit partly because
of high rents and those 25 percent in
fact who are on housing allowance who
are also stock renting because there's
not enough social housing so where will
they all go if the landlord Exodus
continues
some landlords also say they feel
demonized by homeless Charities lobbying
government for change squeezing business
hard our clients are the people at the
sharp end of private renting people who
are being evicted people who are facing
homelessness landlords are well able to
Advocate on behalf of themselves but our
job is to Advocate on behalf of people
who are at risk of homelessness if
landlords continue to sell up at the
current rate with more people forced to
rent long term a housing emergency may
be on the horizon Adele Robinson Sky
News